oh [ __ ] alter geht es auf dem verdoppelt
und willkommen zu community kleinformat
von ihm krankhafter je ist nicht was
geht
ich hab keine ahnung was genau passiert
das erzählt ein bisschen krank ich hab
wohl aber ich tue nur so als wäre ich
hier genau der ahnungslose damit ich sie
man ist ja schon komplett eingeweiht und
zwei community clash ist ein kleines
format was ich am laufen habe und da
kämpfen zwei communitys mit den youtube
seite an seite gegeneinander und das
ganze endet dann in so richtig fetten
king duell eigentlich das relativ
selbsterklärend es mega cool mit einigen
reschl items und so weiter und so fort
und wie gesagt ich selbst erkennt wenn
wir sagen wir schlafen mal oder nein sie
manchmal wurde abwerben wollen wir mit
72 spiele mit 120 spielern kämpfen
jedoch wieder voll
ja ich denke schon am 28 newton wir uns
jetzt und sehen uns dann gleich im feld
wieder ein kind macht dies so leute
jetzt wird auch wieder tipps und nun ein
youtube schreibt kämpft ihr edlen ritter
so ist es okay es geht los freuen ich
habe ein mehr an meiner community
perfekt aber wir sind fast 120 leute
ungespielt macht hier schon welle macht
natürlich auch sie mithalten so
schutzzeit ist beendet und die große
schlacht geht los ist das erste mal dass
wir tatsächlich mit glauben mit 120
leuten kämpfen davor hatten wir immer
zwei leben und 70 leute sehr schön
einige jetzt direkt ich habe erst mal
das tempo raus getan damit man halt
relativ schnell durchkommen weil wir
doch sehr viele spieler sind ok jetzt
schön offensiv wir hatten klar die
kleinen fehlversuch
das simon da irgendwas in seinem video
gepackt hat aber auf jeden fall weiß
jetzt auch gut wieder spielmodus
funktioniert und es dürfte einen fairen
kampf nicht im wege stehen
so also wir sind mit fünf leuten im
vorsprung noch also ihr seht ja selbst
rechts das scoreboard ist relativ stark
so nun ein ist bei mir im team
cyberspace was geht ich dachte er wäre
zu simon gegangen aber freut mich jetzt
erst hat sie aufgeholt
ok
redknapp
brad pitt kita viel zu einfach
obwohl es eigentlich springt ich
verstehe schon die leute die auch immer
auf die die könige gehen ich werde auch
mal ein bisschen offensiven ihr eingehen
weil sie gesagt am anfang können die
könige unbegrenzt oft sterben
so und jetzt mal sehen
den hab ich mir wohl perfekt alter
schwede
mein pc findet gerade ein bisschen mit
den ganzen spielern aber es geht alles
noch relativ klar
also es relativ flüssig noch 22 tode
kann man machen relativ ausgeglichen auf
jeden fall gerade bei unserem test was
ein bisschen weniger ausgeglichen
ich hoffe mal dass keine camper geben
wird jetzt und ja da leute weniger
gespannt wer sich entscheidet ist es
bewegt sich die ganze zeit immer so
circa vier punkte unterschied
und hier ist halt so da der große battle
round so alle leute feierten sie auf
distanz mit drogen verbogen und jetzt
kann ich mir vielleicht ein paar
bogenschützen abräumt wenn die parteien
wenn sie mir jetzt keine keine pfeile
reindrücken aber das machen die ziemlich
gut hält sich immer so konstant kills
tode also man kg ist konstant auf 1
quasi er macht das auch sehr gut hier
und kämpfe einfach weil in sydney
sinn ist fragwürdig aber soll er gerne
machen aber es schlecht für unser team
ok hier ist einfach ja die die
bogenschützen dominieren das ganze schon
relativ deutlich hier gerade ist auch
interessant zu sehen wie sich das für
einen unterschiedlichen spielen jakob
mankel ab wie sich das für den
unterschiedlichen spielen verhält also
gegen wen man ins camp so ich habe
justin zum beispiel waren mega viele
schwertkämpfer drin und so und jetzt ist
dass er in der mitte übertrieben wie
gesagt dominiert von von bogenschützen
okay ach die wohl nicht alle glaube ich
ja die machen das gut sie machen was
echt gut
popstar für die stets weiter
ausgeglichen
noch mal die leute ein bisschen
motivieren dass sie rein hauen
alter schwede das ist sehr sehr sehr
spannend hier guck mal da in der mitte
der stadt und der macht die sind beide
bei simon im team ihr verräter die ich
weiß dass dieser der markt sogar meinen
skin hat wahrscheinlich der justins can
go leute wissen infiniti ist gut dass
trotzdem verlieren sich freuen
okay okay jetzt geht das jetzt geht's
okay ich glaube er war daraufhin in
seinem team versehen habe irgendwie ist
sowieso gerade halb let's play youtube
hat sich mobilisierte wäre
mein bruder dann nun alle sind irgendwie
auch mit ankämpfen
für den very lucky villiger ok also das
ist wahrscheinlich er dann ja dann für
dich weil du ja bei mir im team bist
okay ich bin gespannt wie man führt mit
4 mit vier leuten ist mit viel mit vier
punkten vorsprung man weiß natürlich an
die kritikpunkte entwickelt er gemacht
hat aber ich bin auch chemisch mit nicht
übertrieben gut dabei
dieses mal kommt alter misst bereich 32
sammelt euch wenn wir alle auf einem
fleck sind dann sind wahrscheinlich
effektiver als wenn wir so angreifen
so aber dass ich liebe das gerade das
macht übertrieben spaß komplett
ausgeglichen und so was dieser fällt
einfach finde ich richtig cool
ja da ist felsen genau okay sie dann
fällst du dich nicht okay alter ja aber
gut vielleicht dafür meine leute jetzt
relativ gut im team agieren ja leute ist
macht spaß richtig schwimmen
strategische gerade ja ich bin sehr
gespannt
sie ziehen sich zurück dass ich weiß
nicht was gut ist also schon wieder mit
vier punkten in führungen unglaubliches
kopf an kopf rennen gerade hier richtig
richtig spannend so erstmal ein paar
pfeile reinsetzen
aber die haben natürlich eine menge gute
leute jetzt
ich weiß nicht bei wem wäre um zum
beispiel im team ist aber felsen ist
natürlich ziemlich stark im pvp da hier
der satz verrät nämlich schon wieder
heftig video ein spaß kein vertrauen
verstehen dass man
19.12 ich mag sie man auch gerne aber
wenn ich nicht bei mir im eigenen team
kämpfen
es macht absolut keinen sinn
ihr seid nicht einfach auf den kampf
konzentrieren verdammt jetzt holen sie
grad gut auf alter da muss ich musste
mich ordentlich ranklotzen im entscheid
definitiv hier ist fersen
ich habe aber auch ein bisschen
niedriger apps muss ich zu meiner
verteidigung sagen und der hier der
kollege hat schon sein sagt upgrade oh
gott jetzt kürzer an wie die geier alter
wie die geier konsole an
wenn man da einen schwimm wm ist ich
habe schon länger kein hehl gemacht
kinder gemacht wurde mainz hält wird
sich vor allem verkämpft das war sehr
böse von ihm so ok sehr schön
das freut mich dass die leute auch mit
armee der untoten und so weiter kämpfen
ok felsen ist sieht man ja an beschützen
sehr schön ein habe ich mir geholt der
sogar kit upgrade drin hat er das macht
den leuten natürlich gefährlicher wenn
sie ein katapult drin haben so ok alter
die kämpfen die kämpfen stark ich glaube
jetzt habe ich das gefühl werden wir
gerade ein bisschen reingepresst ok
alter wo mein gott wie sieht das heute
aus wir sind richtig in bedrängnis
wir kennen hier sieht man wollen bei
kings klingt zu töten bringt viele
punkte
ich weiß nicht aber ich würde es halt
liebend gern mein kind noch upgrade aber
gleicher stätte vielleicht einfach ein
paar mal rein schießen ihr okay sie mal
kommt vorangestellt alter schätzt können
wir da was reißen
ich muss echt alle alles geben tino l
die leute kämpfen so gut also glücklich
macht ist übertrieben schwand gerade
hoffe ihr verhältnis einfach immer
weiter rein immer weiter rein okay ist
mir egal jetzt ein kupferrohr ein und
auch verdammt einfach weggeschossen
ich mache reformpakets touchscreen
explodierte ich habe gott verdammt ich
habe auf der tat trieb aber jetzt da
drin explodieren so ist leben noch
sieben leute in meinem team die sind
wahrscheinlich alle da drin irgendwie
fremd fragen mich inwiefern es sinn
macht ich habe es am anfang 1946 fragte
warum ich nicht direkt down wer aber es
kommt ja dann doch relativ schnell wenn
dieses protection vorbei ist krass fünf
leute leben noch hier sind auf jeden
fall ein paar davon aber simons leute
trauen sich hier nicht so ganz
rheinhessen sind wahrscheinlich
vorwiegend bogenschützen
alter schwede felsens auch dabei ein
bisschen ksk noch machen zu einer lebt
anscheinend noch kroko crafter ist noch
an meiner seite sehr schön aber nicht
wo sind die 2
also ich bin auf jeden fall einer 7 und
4 des kaders und gleich im kino spreche
dann sieht man wieder erst auf
jedenfalls 20 punkte was unglaublich
gutes ich werde meine kippa upgraden
aber ich glaube viel mehr kann ich nicht
mehr reißen sagt jeden fall jetzt kann
ich mir gleich noch ein paar leute mit
holen so den titel holen können ja ich
weiß nicht nur wurde biedermann ist aber
die ziehen sich zurück ok perfekt jetzt
geht's los
alter schwede
leute ab 9 punkte gl
teamspeak simon wenig mit mir reden
hallo du wissen mit mir reden
welcher nicht weil ich bin der kreativen
dass ganz viele leute vor mir getötet
aber eine community sehr richtig
spannender fight fand ich super geklappt
zum glück geklappt so dann würde ich
sagen nimm dir zeit und deck dich gut
ein mit items aus dem shop weil dann
geht's ins versus wann der showdown und
ja ich bin sehr gespannt was du so auf
fahren kannst
wir haben jetzt eine zahl countries wir
haben ewig zeit aber du hast halt eine
shop punkte die du rechts um scorsese
und die kannst du jetzt gut ein anwenden
also ein kit upgrade will ich mir auf
jeden fall einmal kaufen für besseres
schwert bessere rüstung und so und dann
den rest tragen die tiere selbst
überlegen was ich habe schon einiges
überlegt ich fühle mich wie ein bisschen
unschlüssig
so sagt wenn du so bist ich bin ich bin
soweit
ja ich bin dann auch soweit ich habe
jetzt relativ klassisches gehalten alles
losging
ich bin ich werde viel glück finden sind
sehr aufgeregt aber angespannt
ich bin darf ich hab da gefragt weil
diese länder perle in der mich geworfen
oder so ist schon mal stark bisher
walter geht es auf dem feld mit der
stadt provo okay eigentlich schädel in
fans so was von kid möchel graz ein
kleiner lecker kanada direktor gerade
ich weiß nie was passiert ist und erst
recht kein was passierte wegen links ich
habe mich schon vier stück gekauft aber
diese mittlerweile aufgebraucht
ein kleiner flecken herzen ich weiß
nicht vielleicht ausgeflogen ich auch
das ist nicht er das ist sich der ernst
also ich hatte mein kind auf level 3d
upgrade hatte sieben oder acht gold
äpfel dabei hatte dreimal doppelsprung
hätte ultra die sachen hier ist nichts
passiert ich werde ein halbherziger bei
waren als wir alleine waren war die
panne bei mir was sachen unentschieden
einigen und dann noch mal irgendwann
eine revanche machen
da wäre ich auf jeden fall sehr
zufrieden ich glaube für mich wäre es
ein ziemlich guter ausgang also wenn es
völlig okay ist dann sehr gerne und
lange aber beim nächsten mal wird er
rasiert leute ich zähle auf euch beim
nächsten mal auf jeden fall auf twitter
aktiv und dann werdet ihr bescheid
wissen wann es wieder losgeht und dann
anders zu sehen momentan auch
geschrieben nachts kommt zu uns besuchen
also war auf jeden fall ist es einfach
das spiel modus also ich bin gerne beim
remake dabei deswegen bin ich auch ganz
ganz schwierig gar nicht so unglücklich
ist und entschieden ist weil ich habe
schon bald auf eine neue runde sache
anders wird das ok cool dann vielen dank
dass du dabei warst
wir sind zwar nicht mal wieder und macht
gute teams
auch